[موسيقى
] في وسط القاهرة ، يظهر مشهد صاخب لشركة
ناشئة ،
هذه هي أول حديقة تكنولوجية في مصر ، إنها من
بنات أفكار أحمد ألفي ، وهو
مستثمر مخضرم وأصحاب رأس مال مغامر
محبط بسبب نقص الموارد
لرواد الأعمال الشباب ، وقد أنشأ
الحرم الجامعي اليوناني الذي استحوذنا عليه بشكل أساسي على خمسة
المباني وتحويلها إلى مركز تقني
للشركات الناشئة للعمل
والتعاون والإبداع وخلق
بيئة لهم تغذي
إبداعهم ونموهم ، تأسس في عام
2014 ويستضيف الحرم الجامعي أكثر من 140
شركة توفر لهم
قاعات اجتماعات وندوات تقنية
مؤتمرات اليوم يلتقي
بالقمة الصلبة مؤسس هارمونيكا ،
تطبيق التوفيق الذي يلبي احتياجات المسلمين
بطريقة تحترم الثقافة
والتقاليد ولدت الهارمونيكا في القاهرة
التي بناها الشباب المسلمون الذين
يتفهمون حقًا المشكلة والألم داخل
مجتمعنا للشباب المسلم للعثور عليه
شريك الحياة المناسب
على عكس تطبيقات المواعدة الأخرى هارمونيكا
والميزات الأقل تميزًا  es التي يتردد صداها مع
الأشخاص في المجتمعات التقليدية بمجرد
تعيين المطابقة ، يكون لدى المستخدمين خيار
استخدام الوضع الحصري الذي يمكنك في
الواقع التحدث إليه مع شخص واحد وأنت
تعلم أنه لا يتحدث إلى أي شخص
آخر وسيعلم أيضًا أن
الفتاة ليست كذلك  التحدث إلى أي شخص آخر ، لذلك
قدمنا نوعًا ما وضعًا داخل ال
طبيق حيث يمكن للزوجين التعرف فعليًا على بع
هما البعض بخلاف أول مباراة ها
مونيكا حصل عليها موقع match.com في عام 2019
شركتهما الأم لب
ض أكثر تطبيقات المواعدة نجاحًا في العالم مث
Tinder OkCupid والكثير من الأسماك التي
نحتفل بها مثل معالم كبيرة
كل يوم مثل أننا نجد رسالة أو
شخص يقول ذلك ، أوه ، شكرًا جزيلاً يا
رفاق ، لقد قابلت زوجتي على ذلك أو مثل
شخص يقول
مع زوجي إنه من الجميل أن
نرى أن  بدأ العمل الجاد الذي وضعناه في هذا العمل في
معالجة هذه النتائج المذهلة ،
حيث يوفر الحرم الجامعي اليوناني
لأصحاب المشاريع الشباب مساحة
للتواصل والإبداع ومع بعضهم البعض لدعم
الأعمال التجارية مثل h  تعمل Armonica على
تغيير ثقافة الشركات الناشئة في مصر ، وفي
مناطق أعماق جون ، CNN
[موسيقى]